alright we are talking to Tom Taylor
some big exciting news a little
unexpected but also makes perfect sense
you are first of all how are you doing
I'm doing very well thanks how are you
pretty good I'm yeah pretty good hanging
in her so the big news you are back for
more injustice so there's going to be a
sequel to the game and they're like who
could we get the right to comic how
about Tom Taylor right yes ya know i'm
very happy i am returning to the
injustice universe the universe that I
both helped to build and help to destroy
so like when because i know we just
found out about the game not too long
ago like when today like first approach
you like hey we're doing this game it's
this being talked for quite a while stay
the truth some you know I've known that
this has been coming for a very long
time I I signed the NDA and I've said
nothing I've been very good and yeah
I've known about it for a long time and
then it's just it's all kind of worked
out with my schedule obviously I never
wanted to leave injustice I love that
universe and I love riding in that
universe and I had to step away to go
and do my TV show the deep and we're now
at this point we were just about to
enter season and it's a great time for
me to jump back on to this so to let
people know so the comics going to be
set between the timeline of the two
video games so do you basically know the
story line of the second game because I
mean you have to know what you you're
allowed to do and where you kind of have
to end or you know not cross any lines
ya know i I've read the script and it's
a very good script the right has done a
great job and yeah there's a lot of plot
points that have talked about which
aren't seen and of course we get to then
bring our stuff into that and we get to
fill in those little gaps things like
super girl who's in the game she
actually rockets to Earth in our conch
so she hasn't been on the planet before
now so she shows up in all of this term
when we get to write her back story so
that's really the surprise welcome
worldsex yeah right exactly but no it's
um we've had a really epic story and
what's fantastic about reading reading
the games groups is there's so much of
our comic that's informed that game like
if you've read our comics and you're
playing that game it'll be a much richer
experience forever
think and we've got it just feels like
we've created this multimedia epic and a
tall tires canonically and it's it's
amazing now the over setbacks I mean
like you said destroying the world and
just like all the crazy stuff that's
happening in the the five years comics
leading up to the first game do you ever
sit back like now what can I do you know
I've already you know we've killed these
characters we've destroyed this and
these people hate each other is like so
what can I do now yeah well the one of
the difficulties or not the difficulties
but the challenge in this was there are
a whole lot less gods among us for this
one because I brutally murdered a lot of
them until their limbs off and stuff and
then more so in the game but the DC
Universe is such a rich universe there's
so many great characters and so many
characters I've always wanted to write
and we have a lot of stuff happening I
mean we have if you've played the game
so it ends with Superman in jail and a
world that's kind of torn apart and
there's a power vacuum and our comic
will be about Batman attempting to
rebuild while other people are trying to
tear things down and he's going to have
to bring more heroes to his side to help
so they're still gonna be angry there's
gonna be like no happy like let's let's
let's hang out Abba parties it's like so
fighting have you read my comics is
always happy there's always happy they
will always be happy when we still
always joy and hope cuz otherwise I
can't tear it down and make you cry now
is a you know I'm assuming some of your
stories gonna kind of maybe possibly
plant some seeds towards the video game
without being because I mean I'm sure
that's under NDA to where you can't hint
at anything so you have to be kind of
sneaky and like I'm gonna write this and
then sit back and not say anything well
no I think we're okay because the comic
will come out in 2017 just before the
game so basically people will have
played the game and they will want to
know what's happened so much like we did
in the last one we were telling stories
and we were very very careful at the
beginning because we had a much longer
lead time and people hadn't played the
game whereas this one people will go
what what what does that mean what's
happened and they can come and read
outcome and can find out so how much of
a like a time period will there be
between like issue 1 and then the game
well or is that something that maybe you
can't talk about no I think I can talk
about that it's some it's a it's at
least a couple of years
before the end of the first game and the
second so we have a big hunk of time to
play with we have a really huge story
for it and then we have a release a tour
just around the time of the game I don't
have the game I don't know what the
release date the game I don't know
either but it is it's 2017 and it will
come up fold again right injustice to to
comicsdigital first make sure you read
it read it right away void spoilers and
then brag to your friends get them to
buy it and then by two comics the
printed the hard covers and everything
on it it'll help you be better at the
game show no it won't that's that's but
you you can you can psychologically tell
people hey I've read I read the comics
I'm gonna kick your butt in the game and
they'll be like maybe it's true maybe
it's true maybe i will learn like some
random Aquaman move just from reading
the comics this is a squared bully where
a triangle x sweep that's right yeah
there is a chapter cold square square
back back forward back on PlayStation
rather I don't some of you I xbox but
yeah the injustice 2017 the comic read
it get the game press which price i get
the game get the game get the game it's
good it's gonna be good
you